I think Hollywood exerts this it sends
this message if you show up I'm going to
deliver your destiny but you got to stay
you have to believe in me and Hollywood
is not going to disabuse you of that
notion it needs you here hyper reason TV
i am tim cavanaugh were here with Nancy
Rommel Minh an award-winning journalist
author of the new novel the bad mother
the story of street kids in Hollywood
tell us a little about the book just you
know general plot and characters and so
sure it's about a pretty small group of
Street kids all between the ages of
about 12 and 19
there is a empty loft that is above the
playmates on Hollywood and Wilcox which
is playmates is still there and they
squat in this loft mostly three girls
stay there but of course there's just
tons of kids in and out the lead
character is pregnant she's 14 she has
her baby and basically everything that
happens on these four corners to these
kids in about a six month period of time
and it's in a real minimalist style I
mean it's it's journalistic and there is
not a lot of you know telling you how to
feel about the there are situations that
are horrible enough I mean certainly if
you if you like genital blistering
you're gonna I don't ever it either in
fiction or in journalism want to tell
the reader how to feel I don't really
think that's my job I'm gonna tell them
what happens and they can you know
they're they can take it and they can
figure out how they feel about it so
yeah I don't want to have meet them
anywhere the kids in this book we should
make clear are these are the type when
we say street people they're the kind of
street people that you know even poor
people are saying we got to get away
from these guys this is like you know in
swollen
a you know calf type of Street folks
affected foot turning tricks their young
to the kids in this book are really
between the ages of 12 and 19 is pushing
it they really are trying to survive
they're just trying to get through the
day and help each other as they can
weather like okay so you know maybe I
can um buy you a sandwich or you know I
can turn a trick so I can buy diapers
for your baby I feel very very tenderly
toward these kids and I hope that comes
through in the book there are certainly
instances in the book people read it and
they feel like this is too much it hurts
too much to look at these kids but I
think you're right people do see these
kids on the boulevard because they are
there and they're in probably every you
know big city they just see them as sort
of faceless and as a problem and I I
didn't see them that way they became
very real to me so no this is not a
reported work contrary to popular belief
contrary to what everybody keeps
insisting even when I tell them no it's
a novel you know I I wrote it it's a
work of imagination people will still
say yes but you're a journalist so you
must have done some you know some
research and you must have talked to
some kids and I think well I I didn't
actually I lived in Hollywood for 18
years
I drove Hollywood Boulevard almost every
day during those 18 years and just by
osmosis and seeing this and being around
it their stories started to seep into me
even though it is fiction an interesting
part of this as these are kids who for
the most part are not actually Hollywood
natives they most have come several of
them come from other parts of California
or other parts of the country and not
all of them from Bad backgrounds no but
they did become you know I think like in
the case of Roche who's my lead male he
his mother developed pretty severe
mental illness and he and his brother
were just lost to the system right and
how do you know they it's sort of like
you know you drop it in at the top and
they they just funnel down they they
wind up in Hollywood the weather's
pretty good here you know maybe there's
a chance that you know Hollywood
promises a lot you know you can come
here and have a destiny though a lot of
these kids aren't there they're not here
to be superstars yeah one I think she
might be ready but yeah they kind of
wound up here do you
the reason that people keep wanting to
think of this as a reported work is that
you really refuse to give anybody you
know the comforts of the bourgeois novel
and nor is there really like a big
attempt to to kind of sentimentalize the
kids or work out their problems for them
or anything like that as my as my
publisher said she said nobody's gonna
read this book and want to be a homeless
teenager in Hollywood it's not romantic
yeah yeah I think people want to
continue to believe that it is reported
because they know me as a journalist who
you know spends time with people for a
long time sometimes in their lives to
write a story like this and maybe
because these kids seem very real to
them that's what they tell me so they
they can't believe that they weren't
real it's a quick read to it's a very
quick read I already have adaptation
will be be a snap yeah we have seen I
report on it a lot all of the money that
gets spent by you know for redevelopment
and so forth we're looking at about five
point five billion dollars have been
dumped on Hollywood by our Redevelopment
Agency you know which now will say oh
look you know the W Hotel is up there
the actual experience of Hollywood is
horrific it isn't you know really a lot
of moving laterally at best in terms of
what's closed up and just what's not
available and how many people you know
people are hanging out on the street
your book certainly does not suggest
there's any kind of solution to this
problem no I don't think there is a
solution to this problem it's just like
you know human beings are human beings
they're going to fail they're going to
fail as parents kids are going to make
bad choices you know they're going to do
too many drugs or they're gonna make a
wrong I mean it's it's we're always
going to have this the city can't solve
this but in terms of Hollywood and the
money dumping into it I have to tell you
we're staying at the Roosevelt Hotel
so I about ten o'clock I go out to grab
some coffee and they're wheeling this
full-size Marilyn Monroe onto the street
Wow we're still she's still we're still
using her Detroit for the same thing but
obviously people wanted cuz they keep
coming back
I'm surprised every time I come back to
LA how little has changed it looks
exactly the same as when I left I don't
know if that's a good thing or a bad
thing but it's it it's not getting any
more beautiful it doesn't seem like it's
getting many more vibrant it's just the
same thing the same thing but I guess
it's working there's a lot of tourists
on the street you saw a lot of tourists
oh yes yes and then I think the most
shocking thing I saw this morning I was
waiting for my coffee and in the coffee
shop was spider-man you know spider-man
stands in front of Mann's Chinese with
the big muscles it's this spider suit
but he had his mask off and it was about
the 60 year old guy who was so
desiccated he looked like a piece of old
driftwood and I'm looking at him I'm
thinking like he's out there you know it
was like with the mask on but put it off
it's just but I get that's also to me
what's so fascinating about Hollywood
like he's the guy in one interview you
get here yeah and why are you still here
people don't really appreciate what a
punishing life it is it is like you've
really gotta have a lot of
stick-to-itiveness and stamina and at
some level be able to say you know I'm
60 year old spider-man and this is my
dream I'm living the dream I think what
it is I think Hollywood exerts this it
sends this message and it says if you
show up I'm going to deliver your
destiny but you got to you got to stay
you have to believe in me so they come
and a lot of people you know it doesn't
happen and they leave but other people
just keep they just stay and they just
stay and they just stay and maybe maybe
that next break is going to happen and
Hollywood is not going to disabuse you
of that notion it needs you here
[Music]
you
[Music]